if I were so a lot of people have
religious trauma fine a lot of people
saw hypocrisy fine I you mean Rel
religous just oh oh no hypocrisy the
movie oh no sorry I just mean I think a
lot of people's hangups on religious you
you brought it up in and I believe
you're special about how um in our
business there being so much atheism and
I just to add to that like you don't
believe in God but you do believe in
like astrology let's just calm down with
the with the atheism you guys you know
what I mean
and I'm seeing all these other little
kind of religions pop up whether it's
keto and I don't know I know you mean
Wellness you know crystals whatever
everyone's what Q andon you know
whatever it is we all you know Terror
management Theory you know we all have
to have something I'm just curious is
someone who is like now kind of going
like all right I'm in the market for a
religion I identify in many ways the way
you do religious wise but after you've
seen a lot of death there's this craving
for like and plan a funeral like the way
Jewish people run a funeral you're just
like after you've had to handle a
funeral there's no they just have it
down you're like I want God good orderly
Direction that's what we say in program
so I always you know I say higher power
I say God because I'm in this program if
someone were to start back up with the
Bible per se like where would they where
would you recommend someone start who
wants to get back on the wagon well okay
I'll I I love this question
and I can't wait to answer it I do want
to say that there are different levels
and one of them that we're talking about
is uh tribal identity and that sounds
like a nasty no no I don't mean it that
way uh a a clan a tribe is one of the
things that you get from religion in
fact it's Rea Osan did my podcast and he
was like 90% of religion is to have a
cultural and uh tribal identity and
that's fine uh I'm not putting that down
for me at a certain point that didn't
cut the mustard and that's okay I don't
go to church uh that's fine my my my my
snoody I want to be like you the point
is to never leave church you're supposed
to maintain that connection but anyway I
understand the covered dish and the and
the funerals and the weddings and also
it's like to be against religion is so
elitist also it's like it's also like
free Child Care on Sundays it's like
there's a lot of reasons people go and
life is really hard yeah and I I
completely get that here's here's I love
your question though
I think that the Bible can be summarized
perfectly uh with two stories it's the
Garden of Eden and the prodical son and
I think that's pretty much all you need
uh the Garden of Eden but I would change
it a little bit not change it but you'll
see the Garden of Eden is we were in
perfect Oneness uh one with God naked so
not literally naked but we were
unclothed unnamed just pure being and
one with God in the garden with God so
that's what in the garden with God does
that make sense yes you tracking with me
I why am I glazing over no I just see
you wincing in a way that's usually
reserved for eating spicy
mustards
I'm well I'll say what I I'll say and
then and then you can ask uh if you have
any follow-up questions okay imagine
that there's a place you could call it
Heaven that is perfect Oneness it's
there's no separation so you are with
God and the way we discuss that or the
way that we metaphorize that is a garden
and
naked then what do we do we eat from the
Tree of Good and Evil that's Duality
right so yes and no that's the world
we're in I my brain was going and I'm
sorry that I glazed over I kind of was
going oh was Eve a a conniving in this
one like did I just take that away is
that unnecessary there's a little uh I
could see how it could be interpreted
misogynistic I I have no tie to this
story so me either meaning I don't have
any need to defend it so yeah I could
see how and I I don't my brain she's not
a conniving she just listens to the
snake my brain dumb dumb okay good I but
Adam's a dumb too he's like what are you
eating I mean every time any story
people are like sitcoms are so sexist
against women that all the I'm like look
at the men in sitcoms they're literally
functionally I'm not allowed to say the
word you know what I mean they're like
hey guys it's just like everything is so
sees it's fine calm down no it's true
that's a Brian Regan bid the guy stuck
in the
blinds um isn't he great one of the best
that's so good anyway there look don't
don't don't start went pulling threads
on the garden of my brain meaning you
could talk about the Garden of even for
thousands of years in fact we have yes
here's what I'm going to say we were in
the garden we were one with God there
was a snake the snake is our ego it's
not the devil the snake represents come
into the world come into this world no
good and evil no yes and no don't be
nothing MH be have pain and pleasure
have winning and losing come into
Duality the tree of Good and Evil so we
ate it what I like about that is we
elected to do it we wanted to do it we
wanted to play this game we wanted to
dance this dance uh we ate it and we got
booted from the garden the part that I
would change is uh
the part that I think the ego wrote from
this story is then God is Mad God puts
up angels with flaming swords to block
us from the garden and kicks us out and
says now child birth is going to be hard
now you won't live forever and you'll
die all this stuff it's like a
punishment that is what I would call the
ego God that's the god that we made in
our image instead of the other way
around so I drop that part but what I
like about that story is that we were
one we elected to eat an apple to
experience Duality MH which is what
we're doing right now p over there
you're over there this is Duality but we
exist but we know it all my daughter I
watch my daughter you're going to watch
your baby they'll be upset sometimes
they'll skin their knee you know what I
mean this is Duality but you'll also
know chocolate chip cookies and this is
the game we're playing it's okay it's a
sacrifice that Oneness made like a
mother this is rert Spyro as well
sacrifices parts of her body and her
life to what to experience to let what
do you mean I mean you're gonna split
from I'm gonna tear from anus if I tear
I swear to God to
pendum am I no my wife didn't okay
you'll be fine you got a huge
cooter